ready be quiet
i GQ this is jet Apatow and these are
mine essentials these are things I can't
live without what is this you may ask
control GX I was at a party and I saw
Jon Lovitz the great comedian and I said
Jon you look great it's my control GX it
reduces your grade you shampoo yourself
with it
your hair gets a little darker you use
it again it gets a little darker what do
you like it you stop using it and then I
used it and I use it way too much and I
look like Paul Manafort I don't dye my
hair because then I had to worry if it
looks right and I'm also trying to look
like a president from the late 1800s
what else do I need
it's mainly haircare products yeah you
may say is the Rogaine working coz that
is a pretty big bald spot that's some
Friar Tuck stuff but you know what it
would be bigger without this it wouldn't
be this it'll be this thank you Rogaine
for at least maintaining it's all about
maintenance I started using the real
game too late to really make a big
difference but I'm hanging in there I'm
hanging in there
a lot of people say to me hey Judd
what's your shampoo and I always say
germ organic as a one of three writers
and you don't mess with the Zohan germ
organic as a shampoo I use simply smooth
it's sulfate free its color safe and
it's made with organic argan oil and you
know you would say a lot of people
probably don't care what I'd wash my
head with and I would say you're wrong
you'd be surprised how many people say
because hair looks pretty pretty lush
what's this I don't know it's called the
hyper volts I know it looks like a sex
toy but you know what it is
[Music]
Oh 30 seconds of this is like getting
200 massages 200 massages for every 30
seconds and this has kept my back from
going out once Leslie and I were on
vacation I play tennis my back went out
I was in bed the entire vacation she did
not enjoy that I had to pee in a bucket
and I just ate some asparagus and then I
had to hand her a bucket of asparagus
pee and the marriage survived but it was
challenged but now I've got hyperbole
and I don't have to worry about that
chum throws so I gotta say two words
jump rope you don't need an expensive
trainer you don't need anything 30 bucks
to a minute take a break for a minute to
another minute to take a break see if
you do it six times change your life
I've never done that by the way but I
haven't told you how do I stay so saying
I'll tell you how because my essentials
are self-help books I'm addicted they
have helped me get to this level of
sanity I don't know what this level of
sanity is but this is where it got me
what are my two favorites I don't know
the power of now at cart Olay he's very
mellow he's European you won't trust
them at first but you should and then my
new favorite one the untethered soul I
know we're being funny on this little
video this pocket will change her life
let me look at one of the many pages
I've look at that look at look at how
into it I am get the untethered soul and
get your [ __ ] together
you don't want to read it untethered
soul cards you should be experiencing
the life that's happening to you not the
one you wish was happening don't waste a
moment of life trying to make other
things happen appreciate the moments you
are given do it the like a cue it's a
great camera
it's autofocus but yet fancy lens so you
don't have to be good at focusing
because it'll do it for you all the
pictures come out great and I'm pretty
sure by showing this camera they're
gonna give me like ten or twenty free
words that's how it works right
come on Mountain commercial no one ever
wants me to sponsor anything I've never
got a nickel to promote anything like uh
like uh no one's better than Leica
essential travel item sound machine it
makes a lot of noise to drown out judge
snoring essential for Leslie not for me
because I don't need it she needs it to
drown out me sounding like I'm dying all
night it's hard to sleep when the person
next to you sounds like they're drowning
now I'm pretty sure you can just get a
nap and you don't need to bring a giant
machine but I like a giant machine an
essential everywhere I go guitar gotta
have one
[Music]
I don't know how to tune it yet
I have no ear for it so I haven't tuned
it I've had it for seven years
everywhere I go I bring to Paul Smith's
suit I just think they're the best suits
I mean I look pretty good in it you'd be
surprised I've lost 12 pounds just from
stress
[Music]
the last thing I have to have and I
always have on me is just Jud items to
plug like crashing season 3 on blu-ray
but you can also stream on HBO max or
the new book it's Carrie Shandling's
book if you like the Zen diaries of
Garry Shandling you'll love this
companion piece scrapbook also don't
forget the king of Staten Island
starring Pete Davidson bill burr and
Marisa Tomei video-on-demand what does
that mean it means if you turn on your
computer it's just there it's just there
waiting for you I'm Judd Apatow for
gqueues essentials
thank you Paul Smith for the best suits
that money can make and thanks Laika
best pictures anyone can snap
you